Three,
two,
one.
Drop the beat.
If I could describe the TED-Ed experience
in one word - exhilarating.
Innovating.
Curiosity.
Contagious.
Oh my gosh, worthwhile.
Inspiring.
Eye-opening.
Oh, that's two words technically but
one word if you put a hyphen, eye-opening.
Students from around the world
come to TED headquarters
to share their ideas.
Hello.
This is the very first time that we have
done an event like this.
Every speaker you'll see today is a member
of a TED-Ed Club, like many of you.
It's so cool coming here and meeting
people from all around the world.
It's just a very fun work environment
and everyone's willing to talk to you
and work with you,
and just show you what they've been doing,
so that's educational experience,
but at the same time
a very fun experience.
And I think that's a really,
really special thing
to meet people who've had
the same experience as me
and we can talk it out and form
this community, like a family.
Think about what motivated you all
to start clubs in your schools.
It's spectacular, it's awesome,
it's all student-based, which makes us
feel like we belong in society
while still standing out.
It's great, I don't want to miss
a second of it.
It's so much fun, it's so much fun.
I've met people from like Jim,
who's so small,
to people who are already in college,
and we're having such a good time,
all of us together.
Dream team, what a dream team!
I've made friends already and I've been
here for four hours, or something.
I feel like I've really
made life-long friends.
Definitely an opportunity that I was glad
that I took it.
If you could improve anything
about your school, what would it be?
I think that this experience to me
is helping me grow as a person
because it's exposing me to many different
things that I didn't know about before.
My mind just went poof
right when I saw it.
I was like there's something
for me to start.
Thank you.
Honestly, it's just so rewarding to see
my idea come to life
and see other people appreciate it
and feel a connection to it.
It means a lot.
All languages are created and molded
by the culture of their speakers.
The languages we speak not only
help us express our thoughts,
but actually shape the very thoughts
we wish to express.
People have asked me,
"So you do this TED Talk, now what
do you do once you're done with this?"
And so I really want to go
somewhere with this.
I don't want to just give the talk
and be done. I want to make a difference.
One of the best
and most effective ways
you can help special education departments
is by creating or joining
a peer helper program.
It makes me feel fulfilled to see
my fellow students get excited
about their education
and about their ideas that
they want to share with the world.
It's wonderful because it gives hope
to me and to my peers
that we will be good leaders
in the future.
We actually will be able to handle stuff
when we're older
and take care of the planet.
It's a beautiful thing. I'm very grateful
for TED and for my club
for making me a better person.
I think it's important that every student
tries to experience this at least once.
Just come, enjoy, and be a part of it.
It is one experience that will probably
get you to New York.
Start a TED-Ed Club today.